Guys, we showed you how to make a bow
out of some PVC and some fiberglass.
Now, it's time to learn how
to make arrows that are so soft,
you can get shot in the face,
and not worry about
whether it's going to hurt.
[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
[Music]
To get started with this build,
there's a couple of
things we need to pick up.
The first is some blank arrows,
and by blank arrows,
I mean ones that
don't have tips on them.
This is usually how you can buy
them at sporting good stores.
It's also important to get
the arrows that are not made of wood.
These are arrows that
are designed for shooting at people,
and wood arrows have
the possibility of breaking
in a way that they splinter,
and keep travelling with a sharp point.
The arrows made from aluminum,
carbon fiber, or fiber glass
aren't going to break
in that dangerous way.
I grabbed these at the
local sporting goods store.
But of course,
they're also available online.
Along with the arrows,
we have four different types of foam,
each progressively
squishier than the last.
I also have a scrap
of some cotton cloth,
a roll of athletic tape,
and some duct tape.
Each arrow will also
use a single penny,
and we've got a
bottle of contact cement
to glue all the pieces together.
Here's the basic idea.
We'll take layers
of these four types of foam,
and glue them all together
in a stacked cylinder.
These will add a nice cushion
onto the front of our arrow,
which will cover
with a piece of cloth,
and secure in place
using the athletic tape.
I have a small circle,
2 inches in diameter,
that I cut out of piece of cardstock.
We now need to cut a few pieces
out of each of our types of foam
this exact same size.
The first type of foam is a sleeping pad.
This whole roll is from
Walmart and cost about $6.
We need to cut 4 of our
2 inch circles out of this foam.
[Music]
Next, we need to cut one circle
out of some floor mat foam.
I have here a scrap piece,
which is perfect,
because I don't need that much.
If you're not able to get
your hands on some floor mat foam,
a few layers of the
thicker foam from craft stores
should work just as well.
Next, I have a foam squishy football
that I bought at the dollar store.
We want another circle
cut out of this foam
about 1 inch thick.
[Music]
Finally, we have some seat cushion foam.
This stuff is super, super soft,
and we want to have 2 inches of this.
If you have some of this foam
that's already two inches thick,
you can use that.
I have a 1 inch thick piece,
so, I'm going to cut out two circles.
We have all of our
foam circles cut out,
and we now need to cut
some holes in our first layers.
Two of them will need small holes,
about the width of the arrow,
and two of them will
need slightly larger holes
just slightly smaller than a penny.
[Music]
Now, like I said, I do want
this slightly smaller than a penny,
so I'm going to try,
and go inside of this trace line
by just about a millimeter.
The holes are cut
in our first layer of foam,
and now, we need to prep
the head of our arrow.
Take a strip of duct tape,
and then tear it in half.
We want to start winding duct tape
around the tip of the arrow head
until the tape is the
exact same diameter as a penny.
[Music]
Our little tape coil is
now just as wide as a penny,
and we want to take a penny,
press it down onto the top of that,
and then use a little bit
more tape to secure that in place.
This is a safeguard,
so, that no matter what happens,
the tip of the arrow
can't push through the foam,
and stab someone when
you shoot them with the arrow.
The arrow tip is prepped.
So now, we need
to start adding our foam.
The first step is going to be
to glue the four bottom pieces together,
making sure that all the holes
are nicely in line with each other.
For gluing foam, contact cement
is the best kind of glue.
It has a very strong hold,
and it goes on nicely.
[Music]
The tip of our arrow is obviously
too small to fit through that bottom hole.
So, we're actually going to do
is slide it down on the bottom.
The fletchings, these little
feathers on the back of our srrow,
are surprisingly flexible,
and will squish down
to fit through that hole.
Now, we can slide
this whole cylinder foam up,
and we need to fit
the head down into the foam.
Because we cut the foam
smaller than the size of a penny,
it's a little bit too big,
but that will help hold it in place
when it's squished in there.
Once the tip of the arrow
is levelled with the foam cylinder.
It's time to add the next layer.
Now, we need to do
the same things
with the next layers of foam.
Our foam football piece,
and then the two pieces
of our furniture foam.
With all of our layers
of foam stacked up,
we can now see just
how much impact that can absorb.
The front really squishy bits
do a lot of absorbing,
and then the back pieces of foam,
just sort of slow down the momentum
as the arrow compresses.
With all of our foam
pieces glued together,
we now want to add
a cloth covering over the whole thing,
so that we don't accidentally
grab a piece and tear it apart.
It's not super important
what cloth use for this.
Something that's not
going to scrape your face
is probably a good bet,
and we just need to
cut a square out of that,
about 8 inches by 8 inches.
Let's center the foam head of our arrow
right in the middle of that cloth,
and then let it drape down on the sides.
At this point, we're going
to use our athletic tape
to secure the cloth onto the arrow.
Piece of tape is just attached
to one corner of the cloth
brought down over the foam,
and secure it around
the neck of the arrow.
Let's do that for
all four corners of our cloth.
Now, we want to take
more of our athletic tape,
and wrap it all the way around,
holding the corners of the cloth down.
Continue wrapping all the way
down the rest of the arrow head.
The wrapping should extend down
off of the arrow head onto the shaft.
Make sure some of the tape
is wrapped all the way around
the gathered bits of
tape on the arrow shaft.
This will help prevent it
from peeling apart later.
We now have an
incredibly squishy arrow head
that soft enough that
it can hit a person at high speed
without worry of injury.
Yesterday, we built our bows.
Today, we built this arrow.
Let's give this a test fire.
[Music]
That's not a real slow-mo.
I'm just smooshing at that.
I'm just smashing it slowly.
Yep.
So, I just took an arrow to the eye.
It was pretty much
a bull's eye or a person's eye.
It was a direct shot right on my eye,
and you know what?
It was startling,
but it didn't hurt.
There's no pain.
My eyes not like
red and bloodshot,
and I'm not going to
the hospital or anything like that.
Like these are very well padded.
With your PVC bow,
and your well-padded arrows,
you are now ready to
start hunting your friends
in a completely non-destructive way.
Grab some friends,
grab some supplies,
and start making these immediately.
Because archery tag is a ton of fun.
Guys, that's not all,
there's more for you to see.
That little box up at the top
will transport you
directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The box at the bottom will
show you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and this bomb here in the middle
will subscribe you to the channel,
so, you never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.